if any of you watching ever had a really
bad day
now obviously you know what I'm talking
about the kind of day when all your
plans were sidelined and nothing went
your way and literally all you want to
do is throw a [ __ ] hissy fit and what
I'm talking about here is how to respond
to a really bad day and I'm not talking
about real tragedy right I'm not talking
about the death of a loved one or a
horrible car accident or illness or war
this is not the topic of this reflection
I'm more talking about those of us who
feel like for the most parts for the
most part are alive our lives are in
flow we're doing kind of what we love or
working towards securing what we love
and things are pretty good until they're
not until you have a really bad day I
remember there was a comic book about
the the Joker from Batman one particular
graphic novel of the Joker said that the
average man is but one bad day from
going insane the Michael Douglas movie
falling down I think Chronicle is what
this kind of meltdown looks like you
know guy who's you know had some
pressure and stress in his life that's
building up and a kind of dead-end job
and maybe he has some aspirations that
he has surrendered and he's sitting in a
car it's 105 degrees and there's a fly
that keeps bucking parking itself on his
face and the traffic is not moving and
you know what he literally jumps out of
his car in a homicidal rage and goes
apeshit batshit crazy and I'm not saying
that we respond that way but it was a
great metaphor it's a nice analogies a
nice visual for what our interior world
often looks like in the face of a really
bad day particularly if you're an artist
you can relate to this line of thinking
you might call it writer's block you
might call it that feeling of just not
tapping into your flow not finding your
note and it's so frustrating right first
and foremost let us admit that in these
moments we become like children throwing
a hissy fit and it's okay
feel the hissy fit feel the frustration
feel the insidious worthlessness and
self-loathing feel the pleasure and
cursing yourself out feel the joy in
calling yourself a useless [ __ ]
uncreative prick whose past is peak and
who will never write another poem or
another [ __ ] chapter you know what it
feels like to doubt yourself to go to
[ __ ] hell
alright the pit of despair of
self-loathing and self-criticism in the
face of a really sucky bad day it's like
a kind of emotional constipation it's
like a [ __ ] existential turd sitting
in your bowels and you can't get rid of
it where is the goddamn existential
enema well right
what is the creative solution to the
problem of a really bad day what do you
do in a moment of writer's block
what are you doing a moment when life is
not in flow because I do a lot of videos
about surfing flow getting in the zone
right hacking into the pocket stewarding
the contents of consciousness turning
life into a work of art a dynamic work
project where you create and perceive
your world simultaneously this is
awesome I've done a thousand videos
about him people assume that I'm in that
space most of the time and I'm not in
that space most of the time I aspire to
be a lean in that direction I design for
that to the best of my capacity but
sometimes my creativity just gets
[ __ ] sideline sometimes the weather
won't cooperate sometimes I'm just not
metabolizing last night's food sometimes
the erican
dinner is too loud and the vibrations
are [ __ ] drilling into my skull when
I'm trying to sleep at night I'm not
perfect and neither are you
and it's okay right we're so privileged
as it is our ancestors would envy the
lives we've got we get to fly across the
planet
we have food in our belly we have a
place to sleep every night we are so
privileged and we are so spoiled and we
have lost our resilience and the
creative in us knows that resilience is
not about what happens or how you react
when things go your way cuz that's easy
you should design for that right design
for things to go your way but resilience
is what you deploy the interpretive
frameworks that you deploy when things
don't go your way when you have a really
bad day when the weather doesn't [ __ ]
cooperate and you got a goddamn heatwave
worse than in the last 100 years right
when you wanted to make your next
beautiful work of art resilience is how
you choose to respond when things don't
go your way are you able to have a sense
of humor are you able to say this too
shall pass are you able to allow
yourself to fall apart to trust that the
present will supersede the past that
whatever fears or traumas or
expectations you never negatively
pre-configure and bring to the doorstep
of every moment conspiring against your
future self that all of that will pass
if you just surrender and you allow the
present to supersede the past that's
where healing comes right when we shed
layers of neurosis we move beyond the
psychosis that is just neurosis pushed
to its extreme let it all can go right
in the words of Terence Mckenna just to
wrap things up nature loves courage you
make the commitment and nature responds
to that commitment by removing
impossible obstacles you dream the
impossible dream and the world will not
grind you under it will lift you up this
is the secret this is what all the
philosophers all the shamans all the
teachers all the wise men those really
touch the alchemical gold this is what
they understood this is the shamanic
dance in the waterfall this is how magic
is done you curl yourself into the abyss
and you realize that it's a featherbed
that's Ezra
[Music]